so I don't live there it's official
Charlie and Dixie D'Amelio have left the
hype house the sisters rep tells ET the
hype house started as a place for tic
toc creators to socialize and create
content Charlie and Dixie created
content with their friends at the house
when they were visiting LA from
Connecticut when the hype house started
to become more of a business charlie and
Dixie stepped away from that aspect fans
speculated that Charlie and Dixie exited
the house before their rep spoke out
they connected the dots after they
stopped seeing the two on the hype
houses
tick tock account they also speculated
that Charlie's recent breakup with hype
House member and co-founder chase Hudson
might have had something to do with it
like a window in April news broke that
the two called it quits after cheating
allegations surfaced the former couple
took to Instagram to let fans know they
are no longer together and wish each
other the best Charlie and Dixie aren't
the first members to say goodbye to the
Ellie mansion in March days eek each
left the house after a creative and
legal dispute about whether she would be
recognized as one of its founders
[Music]
when it comes to the sisters they are
leaving on a much lighter note their rep
made it clear that while their
businesses are separate their
friendships with the members continued
meaning fans will be getting no shortage
of content from them on top of their
tick-tock videos a Charlie and her dad
recently opened up to a new platform you
presumptuous but it sounds like that's
something that's in the works is that
something you guys are actively talking
about yes when do you think this could
happen and where would it live we're
figuring out a lot of stuff right now
we're kind of does this kind of happen
all really very quickly so but we think
it we're going to do it we might as well
go all-in with it and really like
Charlie said just have everyone get to
know us a little bit more closely so
we're in the process of working it out
right now
[Music]